Arthur Schopenhauer was a German 19th
century philosopher who deserves to be
remembered today for the insights
contained in his great work the world as
will and representation Schopenhauer
was the first serious Western
philosopher to get interested in
Buddhism and his thought can best be
read as a Western reinterpretation and
response to the enlightened pessimism
found in Buddhist thought in my
seventeenth year he wrote in an
autobiographical text I was gripped by
the misery of life as the Buddha had
been in his youth when he saw sickness
old age pain and death everywhere the
truth was that this world could not have
been the work of an all-loving being but
rather that of a devil who'd brought
creatures into existence in order to
delight in their sufferings and like the
Buddha
it was Schopenhauer's goal to dissect
and then come up with a solution to this
suffering it's simply the fault of
universities that Schopenhauer has
always been taught in such a dry
academic way that it has stopped him
from being widely known read and
followed and yet in truth this is a man
who no less than the Buddha deserves
disciples schools artworks and
monasteries to put his ideas into
practice it's not too late sure but how
his philosophy starts by giving a name
to a primary force within us which he
says is more powerful than anything else
our reasoned logic or moral sense and
which Schopenhauer terms the will to
life in German the villa zum Libin the
will to life is a constant force which
makes us thrust ourselves forward cling
to existence and look always to our own
advantage it's blind dumb and very
insistent what the will to life makes us
focus on most of all is sex from
adolescence onwards this will thrums
within us turns our heads constantly to
erotic scenarios and makes us do very
weird things the most weird of which is
fall in love all the time Schopenhauer
was very respectful of love as one might
be towards a hurricane or a tiger he
deeply resented the disruption caused to
intelligent people by infatuations or
what
called crushes but he refused to
conceive of these as either
disproportionate or accidental in his
eyes
love is connected to the most important
underlying project of the will to life
and hence of all of our lives having
children while all this noise and fuss
about love he asked why all the urgency
uproar anguish and exertion because the
ultimate aim of all love affairs is
actually more important than all other
aims in anyone's life and therefore it's
quite worthy of the profound seriousness
with which everyone pursues it the
romantic dominates life because
Schopenhauer wrote what is decided by it
is nothing less than the composition of
the next generation the existence and
special constitution of the human race
in times to come
of course we rarely think of future
children when we're asking someone out
on a date but in Schopenhauer's view
this is simply because the intellect
remains much excluded from the real
resolutions and secret decisions of its
own will why should such deception be
necessary because for Schopenhauer we
would never reliably to reproduce unless
we at first quite literally lost our
minds
this was a man deeply opposed to the
boredom routine expense and sheer
sacrifice of having children furthermore
Schopenhauer argued that most of the
time if our intellect were properly in
charge of choosing who we could fall in
love with we would pick very different
people to the ones we actually end up
with but we're ultimately driven to fall
in love not with anyone we'll just get
on with well but with people whom the
will to life recognizes as ideal
partners for the project of producing
what Schopenhauer bluntly called
balanced children all of us are a little
bit unbalanced ourselves he thought were
a bit too masculine or too feminine too
tall or too short too rational or too
impulsive
if such imbalances were allowed to
persist or were aggravated in the next
generation the human race would within a
short time sink into oddity the will to
life must therefore push us towards
people who can on account of their
compensating imbalances cancel out our
own issues a large nose combined with a
button nose promise of perfect nose he
argued that short people often fall in
love with tall people
more feminine men with more assertive
and masculine women unfortunately this
theory of balancing attraction led
Schopenhauer to a very bleak conclusion
namely that a person who is highly
suitable for producing a balanced child
with is almost never that we can't
realize it at the time because we've
been blindfolded by the will to life
very suitable for us we should not be
surprised he wrote by marriages between
people who would never have been friends
love casts itself on people who apart
from sex would be hateful contemptible
and even abhorrent to us the will to
life's ability to further its own ends
rather than our happiness may
Schopenhauer implied be sent with
particular clarity in that rather scary
lonely moment just after orgasm he wrote
directly after copulation that devil's
laughter is heard watching the human
spectacle Schopenhauer felt deeply sorry
for us we're all just like animals
except because of our greater
self-awareness far more unhappy than
animals there are some poignant passages
where Schopenhauer discusses the lives
of different animals but he dwells
especially on the mole a stunted
monstrosity his words that dwells in
damp narrow corridors rarely sees the
light of day and whose offspring look
like gelatinous worms but which still
does everything in its power to survive
and perpetuate itself we're just like
moles and just as pitiful we are driven
frantically to push ourselves forward we
want to get good jobs to impress
prospective partners we wander endlessly
about finding the one and are eventually
briefly seduced by someone just long
enough to produce a child and then have
to spend the next 40 years in misery
with them to atone for our errors
Schopenhauer
was always beautifully and comically
gloomy about human nature there is only
one inborn error he wrote and that's the
notion that we exist in order to be
happy so long as we persist in this
inborn error the world will seem to us
full of contradictions for it every step
in great things and small we are bound
to experience that the world and life
are certainly not arranged for the
purpose of being happy that's why the
faces of almost all elderly people are
deeply etched with disappointment
Schopenhauer offers two solutions to
deal with the problems of existence the
first solution is intended for rather
rare individuals that he called sages
sages are able by heroic efforts to rise
above the demands of the will to life
they see the natural drives within
themselves towards selfishness sex and
vanity and override them they overcome
their desires live alone often away from
big cities never marry and can quell
their appetites for fame and status in
Buddhism Schopenhauer points out this
person is known as a monk but he
recognizes that only a tiny number of us
in any generation will ever go in for
such a life the second and more easily
available in realistic therapy is to
spend as long as we can with art and
philosophy whose task is to hold up a
mirror to the frenzied efforts and
unhappy turmoil created in all of us by
the will to life we may not be able to
quell the will to life very often but in
the evenings at the theater or on a walk
with a book of poetry we can step back
from the day-to-day and look at life
without illusion the art Schopenhauer
loved best is the opposite of
sentimental Greek tragedies the
aphorisms of La Rochefoucauld and the
political theory of Machiavelli such
works speak frankly about egoism
suffering selfishness and the horrors of
married life and extend a tragic
dignified melancholy sympathy to the
human race it's fitting that
Schopenhauer's own work fitted his
description of what philosophy and art
should do for us it too is deeply
console and it's morbid bitter pessimism
for example he tells us to marry means
to do everything possible to become an
object of disgust to each other every
life history is the history of suffering
life has no intrinsic worth but is kept
in motion merely by desire and illusion
after spending a lot of time trying yet
failing to be famous and trying yet
failing to have good relationships
towards the end of his life
Schopenhauer did eventually find an
audience who adored his writings he
lived quietly in an apartment in
Frankfurt with his dog a white poodle
whom he called Atman after the world so
loved the Buddhists but whom the
neighboring children less respectfully
referred to as mrs. Schopenhauer shortly
before his death a sculptor made a Fame
bust of him he died in 1860 at the age
of 72 having achieved calm and serenity
he is a sage for our own times someone
whose bust should be no less widespread
and no less revered than that of the
Buddha he so loved
you